we sued the organizers of the
charlottesville rally the white
supremacists who came down to
charlottesville and basically wreaked
havoc culminating in a terror attack
where james fields drove his dodge
challenger through the crowd of 29
counter protesters killing heather heyer
and injuring a number of folks including
our clients and so we took him to trial
[Music]
so we're here with mikey [ __ ]
block
you know what i mean yeah second best
second best catcher to come out of
washington dc second in the mid to late
90s you know what i mean behind you is
true
would you say you were you you were a
better baseball player than me would you
say would you say that i wouldn't say
that what would you just learn like like
yeah talk about me as a baseball player
and then talk about yourself as a
baseball if you could just talk about
him as much
yeah yeah all that [ __ ] legal [ __ ]
and all the great [ __ ] you did we'll get
that stuff but yeah let's talk about me
um
i think my favorite john bernthal
baseball moment
was um do you remember when remember
riyadh i do remember riyadh you remember
rihanna was pitching
and um
and john john's behind the plate
calls a curveball yeah
riyadh throws this i don't know what you
call it it was like a
just this floater and it just it was
almost like in slow motion and john's
sitting there
doesn't move
just reaches out with his bare hand and
catches it like this
stands up
throws about 100 mile
fastball back at him yells to everybody
throw harder
it was slim pickings for pitchers though
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i think that
sort of encapsulates you as a as a
leader but you were like i mean you were
a [ __ ] good baseball player man did
you go on and did you play in college i
played a little bit i played uh i played
one year at wesleyan one year and you
played hockey too right for
half a year at wesleyan and then i got
hurt i got a um i tour i got a hernia
yeah and then then you were introduced
to fun and yeah bye-bye sports
yeah and then the coach was like you
probably shouldn't play anymore you
weren't that good anyway
so
uh that was about it but um yeah yeah
man well i mean we have uh
you know
everybody gets mad at me on this show
because i never do like proper
introductions i just started you know
yeah surprising
yeah you you know
i don't follow protocol that well but
you know we we grew up together i love
you i've known you a long [ __ ] time
we've gotten into a lot of trouble
together we've had a lot of good laughs
together um you've uh
you've you've made uh quite a [ __ ]
life for yourself man and um you've done
some amazing things uh you're a new dad
which is the best of of them all true um
uh which we were just talking about but
i just want to like just just to let the
audience know kind of who you are and
what you've been up to just talk a
little bit about
sort of what you've been getting a lot
of attention for sort of recently the
the major case that you just kind of
came off of and yeah let's just hear a
little bit about like what that was yeah
all right well thank you and i
appreciate great to see you first of all
you too mikey really appreciate being
here great to see gareth yeah we got the
professor with us yeah we got the
professor with us yeah whenever i have
really smart guests yeah we got to bring
it's like it's someone who can actually
ask questions that's it dude yeah you
got to bring the brain trust yeah yeah
i'm saying um so yeah tell us mikey so
uh i recently finished uh trying the uh
uh
federal litigation in charlottesville
virginia we sued the organizers of the
charlottesville rally uh the white
supremacists who came down to
charlottesville and basically wreaked
havoc on the town ultimately um
you know culminating in a terror attack
where james fields drove his dodge
challenger through the crowd of 29 or so
counter protesters killing heather heyer
and injuring a number of folks including
our our clients and so we took him to
trial um and
we filed suit um in
october of 2017 so about two months
after the rally happened
um it has been four years of litigation
wow um
and we just tried the case in
charlottesville about five blocks from
where the the terror attack took place
um and fortunately won a 26 million
judgment against the organizers of the
rally who really are kind of the leading
white supremacists in this country so
and the neo-nazis and white supremacists
that that organized that rally that's
richard spencer who who are who are the
it was directly against him yeah so we
sued um we really tried to focus on
the folks that were actually
culpable for organizing and perpetrating
the violence so there were hundreds of
people that came out to the rally and we
were not suing people that were just
there to express
their views who however you know heinous
those views are um so we sued richard
spencer
jason kessler a guy named chris cantwell
matthew heimbach
a guy named michael hill michael tubbs
um a couple others and then basically
the organ the white supremacist
organizations that they
run and as well as james fields the
driver of the car
and so and the theory of the case was
that basically this was a conspiracy to
commit racially motivated violence
um and not just a
you know
a first amendment
rally to sort of express
you know heinous views and who are the
plaintiffs in the case like who who
hired you guys and was it pro bono work
how did it all come about yeah so the
plaintiffs were folks that were injured
in some aspect of the rally so the rally
was actually two nights it was friday
night august 11th where
um
there was a torch march and sort of this
iconic
photo you see these photos of 500
neo-nazis with with torches marching
through university university of
virginia's campus so that resulted in a
fight basically an assault that that
on about 20 students and counter
protesters
some of our plaintiffs were injured in
that
attack
and then others were injured the next
day at the events that took place on
saturday august 12th including a number
of folks that were injured by
um by the car um the case was originally
brought by roberta kaplan who um uh
whose firm i was at
and
she basically first of all she's a real
just pioneer civil rights
uh leader in this country
she actually won united states versus
windsor which was the case that gave us
gay marriage um
and then she started this firm that was
focused on
um among other things public interest
litigation and using the law to like you
know fight people and and um
causes that are you know
that are harming society and can be
redressed through litigation so
um and this was sort of the first and
kind of biggest case she brought
and so actually what happened was um as
soon as trump did his
you know very fine people on both sides
thing which upset
the country but a lot of people in the
firm in particular
um
robbie was on a plane two days later to
charlottesville and and met people that
were injured and um and and basically
put together this case mikey you you
said you you said before i mean i mean
obviously we'll go into this but like
you know the difference between people
who are going to express their views and
then the people who are going there like
with the express with the express sort
of interest and and design plan yeah to
commit violence um look man obviously
you've done like
countless days and years and months of
research on this you have an intimate
knowledge of the events and all that you
know how do you
how do you decipher that and like what
what
what percentage like how do you decipher
that
what what sort of like
bluster and and bravado and [ __ ]
that you hear online versus what are
like the actual plans to go commit
violence yeah that's a great question so
um
the short answer is that it it was
pretty explicit um
the
most of the rally was planned on this uh
online platform called discord um which
is which is uh supposed to be for video
gamers to chat while they're playing
video games you probably
play a bunch of video games still um
and uh
and but so they had this like secret
private
um
chat room that was called
charlottesville 2.0 which is what they
called the rally and that's where they
planned most of what took place and you
know i think anybody reading it um
reading the the actual things that they
discussed wouldn't have any doubt that
they were
um that they were coming to plan
violence so it was a very
um it was explicit they talked about
fighting tactics they talked about
whether it's legal to run over counter
protesters in virginia um they thanks a
lot um they talked about
how to use
tools that sort of can look like first
amendment tools but to use them as
weapons
like flags like bring flags but fortify
them you know with with pvc piping so
that you know for for better thumping
um
it was a it was really really
vivid and explicit um and
i should say that you know we also care
about the first amendment and which is
um as somebody who's talked a lot of
[ __ ] yourself probably as myself
is there any examples i mean can you
give me an example of something that you
like where do you draw that line and i
really want to go into like the personal
yeah you know how personal this was for
you and and and where that line is drawn
like an illegal issue but how do you
draw the line between is this guy just
talking [ __ ] to know this is in fact
this guy's going there to incite
violence yeah um
i think it's a combination of things
first of all the statements themselves
are uh
were explicit um but but second of all
if you look at the statements
um
and then the actions and then how it
plays out and then how they react
after the fact
um sort of looking back you can see
that they talked about doing a specific
kind of violence they planned and they
took steps to
commit that kind of violence right so
they said they talked about flag poles
and you know fortifying them with nails
and pvc piping and um and then they
bought
you know and they brought flag poles and
then they used flagpoles to beat people
up and then they celebrated the violence
that they committed and so
um and and you know sort of proudly um
and so
you know when you look at the whole
progression there were people that were
online that were just sort of talking
trash
um
and they didn't get sued but the ones
that were like
you know uh
they talked about it for months they
planned it they executed it and then
they celebrated it
you know those guys in our view
wanted this to happen and so that's who
we sued so you were talk a little bit
about like
when you were actually in this trial i
know that you know richard spencer for
one defended himself and kept trying to
say no no you know that was just kind of
the culture of the thing yeah we didn't
actually mean it we'd always joke about
that stuff and never do anything
and you used a lot of his own words
against him like you played a lot of
footage in the case like talk about how
you put that together
in a little bit about like four years of
your life going to this and like a lot
of change in the country in that time
yeah how did you guys feel as you went
through that process too so one of the
things that we were up against is
um which is a lot it sort of goes to
what you're asking about is like this
like trash talk
environment and there is a lot of
[ __ ] talk um and and that's not illegal
um
part of what we
discovered and tried to establish and i
think did establish for the jury is that
that is a
tactic in white supremacist culture um
is to
uh
you know is to set up this defense of
plausible deniability by claiming we
were just joking and so how do we
prove that
one thing is we had phenomenal experts
who have studied white supremacists and
have embedded themselves with white
supremacists for
decades
who came and testified that this is a
tactic that they've been using for
you know for decades literally is to
sort of um
talk about
horrible
plans this sort of tongue-in-cheek way
execute those plans and say that we were
just joking it's just so cowardly you
know what i mean i was just joking yeah
i mean that's like what a [ __ ]
four-year-old right yeah i mean
yeah actually there's this great
line in in spencer's testimony where he
when he was confronted with a number of
the stuff he said um his defense was
like that's just the seven-year-old me
um which is sort of the built-in defense
um
we also had explicit documents where
um one was called the style guide it was
basically the white supremacist style
guide that literally says
um when you are talking about you know
plans or whatever do it in a joking way
so that you essentially have plausible
denials where is that style where's that
written uh well so it came out at trial
it was a document that was um
circulated amongst these yeah
yeah so there's a site called the daily
stormer which is um you know you
probably subscribed
there's a site called the daily store
where uh
where
um that is like the white supremacist
you know
blog basically um and this was written
by the guy who founded the daily stormer
um that was a style guide for writing on
the daily stormer um
and we also had a woman who
was in one of these groups and actually
got very
high up in the group she was sort of
radicalized and then she got out and
um
and she testified for us and was like
and she testified about the style guide
and she testified about like this is a
tactic this is what they do
um
and so you know we were ready for
the defense of this is all we're just
joking yeah um and it's pretty well
established you know sort of documents
and people and experts and
um but in your mind in your mind you're
hard from all
from like kind of going through all this
the organizers of this event you know
these guys that you know put this thing
out there the guy especially the guys
that you tried yeah
do you feel like they were hopeful that
there would be violence do you think
that they they were
that that that that it could have kind
of gone either way or was this
definitely like where do you think their
minds were in in terms of like was this
exactly what they wanted yeah
because they even talked about i i feel
like i read about they talked about
hitting protesters with with cars like
that was something they talked about
correct yeah they talked about it uh a
number in a number of places in in the
planning
sessions leading up to the rally um and
so yeah i think a lot of this is exactly
what they wanted how does violence
sort of achieve their natural their
their master plan like what yeah what is
in it for them
i mean aside from oh i get to like beat
up somebody who thinks differently than
me or looks differently than yeah or
like what what's in it for them to
commit this violence and do you perceive
they have a plan like do these guys have
a plan or is it just sort of like
disorganized chaos that they're trying
to sell like these aren't the skinheads
from like down at you know the exorcist
steps in dc who just weren't looking for
a fight right i mean this is a
nationally organized group of people
yeah so i there's a lot i think i think
i think you guys touched on a lot of
different issues there so
um i think historically so one of the
things our experts
talked about and testified at trial is
that violence has been a tactic for
white supremacists since you know the
1860s since the clan started
um uh you know they were committing
violent acts against
black people for the purposes of hurting
black people for the purposes of
terrorizing the community um voter
suppression voter suppression for the
purpose of establishing dominance um so
that's one
um that's one thing is that violence has
been a
um a key part of white supremacist
culture for 150 years um
so
you know so what do these guys want um i
think there's some of that i think
there's some that like like to fight and
they like to beat up people that you
know disagree with their views um
there's also a lot of talk within white
supremacist culture about
the race war
um and there is this fear
uh that white supremacists stoke that
white people are being replaced that you
know sort of politically they're being
replaced and that uh demographically
they're being replaced that they're
gonna actually be the minority in in 20
years
um
and that we need to according to them
sort of hold the line and so
what a lot of white supremacists
including our defendants talked about is
that they want a race war they want to
they want to spark a race war they want
to and there were folks that went to
charlottesville hoping that this was it
that this was the beginning of the race
war um
and so what do they get from that they
get um they get attention they get i
think there's this i mean a lot of it is
like you know real sort of fantasy
conspiracy theorists like crazy [ __ ]
um
but i think there are there are at least
folks that say
um you know we want this is going to be
the start of the race for and it's going
to spark it and then
you know
we're going to get two sides and we're
going to win and we're going to
establish our dominance i mean is it
that crazy i mean like i just like when
you look at
you know the percentage i really want to
like hear your opinion of like who these
people are what like like
it's um
i i guess i guess like what is it like
there is there a fine line between
the folks that
you know
would would consider themselves to not
have a racist bone in their body but
they feel like the election was a w you
know what was stolen right and these
folks that even you know you get you get
behind closed doors with you know
white men in even progressive circles
and they'll start saying how they can't
get work and how the the scales not
tipped anymore because of different
kinds of you know it was affirmative
action 10 15 years ago but now there's
all this i mean like i just feel like
that line um is is uh is getting more
and more narrow and and i'm just
wondering do you
it is the goal here to try to get those
folks over to this side i mean that's
like
i mean i think obviously we know i'm no
like history buff but i feel like that's
exactly kind of like what the nazis did
in in in germany it's like you know
blame find a scapegoat yeah you know
blame the ills of society on a group and
then like
increase in numbers and then go to
[ __ ] town i mean is that part of the
the the race war master plan
um i think for some of them yeah i mean
i and a lot of this came out at trial
that these guys love adolf hitler i mean
and you know one of our defendants was
um the national socialist movement um
who uh
you know style their group on the nazi
party um one of the i mean a lot of them
how big is that how big is that here in
this country um
it's not clear i mean they don't you
know they don't have rosters so it's
hard to say that's your opinion i mean
what do you think what's your guess like
a couple hundred in that group i mean
but then
so so the actual membership in these
groups is pretty small right but when
you think about the people who kind of
are the wink-wink nod nod group right
like the ones you aren't actually
they're not members of the organization
yeah but they look at that stuff and
kind of tacitly they're okay with it
like how big is that yeah i think when
you look at at our country yeah i mean
so
it's a great and
unanswerable important and unanswerable
question um i guess i'd say a couple
things um first of all
one of the things that i think we tried
to do at trial
is to make clear that these defendants
are not your sort of like
run-of-the-mill conservatives and these
are not um you know and these are not
trump
supporters right these are guys that in
fact a lot of them hate trump um
in part because they think trump's not
racist enough for them um
so these are not like
these are not people that i feel like
or i think many people would feel like
you know we just have sort of a
political difference like these are guys
that actually
um
hate black people and really hate jews
and want violence
um and so that and i think it's a stat
group i think is not huge although
they're vocal and they're they can be
destructive
um
you know like but it's certainly a
spectrum and
you know we wanted to make sure that we
weren't going after anyone who's who's
you know gray i mean so you you
cross-examined richard spencer for hours
and you know you spent four years of
your life working on this thing you're
in a courtroom standing up there with
him
you must have had a lot of emotions you
had to pack away i mean your family is
jewish you're talking to this guy who
organized a rally where people are
literally out there chanting you know
jews will not replace us like how did
you handle that in the moment and like
compose yourself in a way that got to
the right outcome yeah so that's a great
question so yeah and it was four years
of
that i mean so i deposed a lot of these
guys including spencer and chris
cantwell and um and and some of them
made it explicit in depositions um
uh it's called an [ __ ] at trial
um
right they were right about that
one yeah um these guys aren't crazy
under what under what circumstances were
you called that
so in a deposition um while i am
questioning one of the defendants for
seven hours um
uh and i think i asked you know i mean i
was challenging these guys right because
which is which is my job and
um and they don't love being challenged
generally i mean nobody does and they
really don't love being challenged by a
new york jew yeah um and and it's seven
hours and people get tired and stressed
and like you know there were some
explosions and then and that's when a
lot of the like
core beliefs came straight up yeah um
and you're right like i am jewish
my grandparents were
escaped from nazi germany uh my
grandmother got to this country on the
night of kristallnacht
my grandfather went back to germany
as one of the ritchie boys to fight um
for the americans
um and so
um and that has always been a
really
inspiring thing for me a sort of great
act of real patriotism and courage
um so
yeah there's a lot of and just you know
anti-semitism and racism is like is
terrible and despicable and just and to
be confronted with it particularly for
uh three and a half four years is um is
emotional so
um
you know i think um
i think for me
i mean i sort of was able to
i guess compartmentalize i mean because
it's the same you know this the case is
not about
me um and
um
and in this kind of i don't know if this
is sort of the irony of
litigation but like
the things that were horrific
and
you know heinous and vivid and insulting
were also great evidence
um and so
you know if i'm like
if i have my lawyer hat on which is sort
of the hat i had to have on
a lot of times i would sort of listen to
these like terrible things and you know
and a large part of me was like well
that's going to be great for us yeah
right right it's kind of interesting i
mean i i must feel good for you though i
mean it feels good for me like sitting
here with you that as a lawyer you still
exist in a world where like there is a
decision on facts and facts matter and
it feels like the world we live in now
like we live in a very blurry world
where people are entitled to their own
facts
where the natural blurring of lines the
ability to distance yourself from things
that you've said the gaslighting that
happens
like that all is like that's a societal
phenomenon that's just [ __ ] terrible
for everybody yes and it must feel nice
to like walk into a court of law and
actually still operate in a world where
you actually can't do that there is a
final decision made on what fact is and
what truth is and you walk out the door
with an answer to a question like that
yeah that's absolutely right i mean um
and it was a huge fear
of mine that we would go in and get a
jury that um
saw this as politics and that that that
was going to base a verdict on their
politics um and so
and and we tried to control for that as
best we could so
um karen dunn who's also was another
lead lawyer who's just a spectacular
trial attorney and she
gave part of the opening statement and
and part of it was
from the get-go this is not about
politics um we're not
here to debate the first amendment we're
here to show you evidence of racially
motivated violence um
and then secondly we try you know it was
a
uh it was a big part of
um
jury selection that and the western
district of virginia which is the
federal district where this was tried um
is very mixed i mean there's
charlottesville which is um you know
sort of leans
progressive but it goes out to the
border of kentucky
which leans the other way and we really
wanted open-minded jurors i felt like if
we had open-minded jurors we were going
to win um and if we ended up with jurors
who
you know who just were not going to
listen to facts then we were in trouble
um but yeah and so that like that was
one of
i think a big fear of mine and something
that i think is comforting in some sense
the question in my mind was always are
are we going to have jurors that listen
to facts and i think it's it's
reaffirming you did right because i mean
i think about it and it's like i totally
really culturally live in a moment where
you know number one like permissibility
has been granted like you said to things
that weren't before like whether you
you know
however you think about donald trump
saying they were really good people on
both sides right that is
giving permission from the highest level
right to that kind of behavior right
yeah it's like the second you equate
both sides of what happened in
charlottesville you're saying there's a
rationale for both of those sides
existing right yeah and then the second
piece of it is the plausible deniability
of what people say
and then afterwards saying no no you're
just misinterpreting what i said yeah
right and i think all of that seemed to
come together in this one case for you
yeah where it's like you've given
cultural permission for people to behave
in a certain way and how does that
impact a juror's mindset yeah and then
the other thing is this notion of
plausible deniability which allows
everybody to walk away from words that
came out of their own mouths and and you
guys managed to actually fight through
that and come to uh come to a good
outcome which is in in some ways it's
kind of amazing
yeah i think that's absolutely right
there's something very comforting about
the fact that
basically what you said before that we
presented the facts
and a
um a jury of
um our client's peers that was a mixed
group um politically from the community
and racially
um
said uh you know this is not okay and
um and that's great and that's very
comforting
i totally agree with that
and
talk just a a um i'm just wondering so
in in just the course of your life right
i mean you because i mean you you you
i mean you what you went to college
right and you went to law school like
when did you like
when did you like pull it all together
man
like when did you like what you said
what did you do when did you stop making
correct calls yeah i mean like it's just
that happens i mean you were i i mean
like i mean you were just a complete
[ __ ] maniac like i mean when did you
pull it all together yeah i actually
think sports helped me a lot um it's
sort of like you know
practice uh
you know the practice turned into
studying and reading and um
and so yeah so you if you look at my
uh
my
college
uh
transcript
there's a i mean there's a very very
clear line between my first three
semesters yeah um and then my last five
semesters
yeah and then and then and and then you
went to law school yeah right where did
you go to law school i went to harvard
you went to harvard yeah you [ __ ]
do you know that i ran into this yeah
this [ __ ] guy went home he went to
harvard i know and i i don't know if you
remember this i was in cambridge because
i actually worked at harvard uh before i
went there at the public interest office
um i think it was the summer of 2000.
i'm in this field yeah um i believe it
was called cambridge common
i really remember beverly when i was
playing soccer
um i hear this
uh
this really really offensive
um i'm sure you were super offended i
was really offended yeah um
and i turn and it's you and you uh you
come over to me and i was like
what the [ __ ] how would you be here yeah
yeah
and you pulled out your harvard art
student card and you said i go to
harvard [ __ ] and i like imagine
my shopkins
you know it was like like whatever
everything i could forge anything these
days you know like did you get that
electro yeah and his actual photo was on
it yeah and i was like
how the [ __ ] did that happen how does
that work yeah how does that work and um
and you told me about how you got in
there and i will never forget that what
you said is that you were gonna go give
a speaking tour to tell all the kids in
america that this is this is how you get
to harvard and i was really like talk
about being afraid for our country
that
i was like we're in big trouble
[Laughter]
so but
yeah so you [ __ ] so yeah so you're
there and then you get out and i imagine
i mean there was a like
and then you first you're you're a
public defender correct uh yeah well so
i i clerked for a couple years i clerked
for um first a judge in new orleans who
was a former criminal defense attorney
who was awesome and then um and then i
clerked for uh a judge in chicago who
was great
and then i went to a firm for three
years in dc
um and then i went to the public
defender's office so so
what made you wanna you know
frankly like leave like a a white shoe
firm
making a bunch of money and go work as a
public defender you had like every
option i mean from what i've heard is
that you've had every option in the
world open to you could have made all
the [ __ ] money in the world and then
you decided to go be a politician
garbage yeah yeah yeah um
yeah so i was at i was at this firm and
i was like
and it was phenomenal i love the firm i
love the people um great experience i
just was like
not representing people i was
representing huge corporations um and i
just you know it wasn't like it didn't
inspire me and i wanted to
i wanted to be in court i wanted to
represent people i wanted to represent
people that were like in real trouble um
and so i just yeah i left i was at the
far for three years and then
um
and then i went to the bronx defenders
um
and it was i you know i i would say the
best job of my life so i started in 2011
in
um in the bronx and
um definitely the war i mean the war on
drugs is still
having a huge
impact
but at that time in 2011 it was also
kind of the height of stop and frisk in
new york right um
and that was
uh devastating to you know to
communities like the bronx um
and so
um because you have
just
hundreds and thousands of
um
generally young people of color
that are
um
you know stopped and frisked and
arrested um
sort of
without basis and so
it
um
and you know my first particularly my
first three or four years at the bronx
you would see it just
constantly so so we would um you pick up
cases in arraignments you could go
that's when um
the judge decides whether or not to set
bail and and so you go and you meet your
client and they're locked up and
um
and i just can't tell you how many times
i met somebody usually a young person of
color and i would say you know they
would be charged a lot of them like a
lot of weed charges which is
kind of crazy to think about at this
point but a lot of just possession of
weed charges and you'd go in
um and you'd read the complaint and the
complaint would say
um
you know this person
was walking down the street and carrying
a
you know an amount of weed in their left
hand
which is
nuts because no one does that um
certainly not in the bronx um
and uh and so you'd you know you'd meet
this person and you'd say what happened
and they would say
um the cops jumped out at me i i heard
the cops jumped out at me
hundreds of times you know they'd say i
was walking down the street some of them
would say i had weed in my pocket
which was actually um
not a criminal offense it was not legal
but it was not a misdemeanor to have it
you know in like not open to the public
and so i had tons of clients that would
be like i was walking down the street or
i was hanging out with my friends or
whatever cops jumped out at me threw me
up against the wall
you know searched me searched my pockets
threw the weed on the ground charged me
with possession of weed um and then you
know and then they'd write it up that
you know that it was open in public view
because that's what makes it a
misdemeanor um and so your question was
sort of how is that
devastating i mean it's um
it's it you just see this like entire
community of um
folks that are just like living
basically in a police state and harassed
you know for
doing something that
you know
folks or
the same number of people are doing
you know on
uh you know on the upper west side um
that are not getting
just hounded and harassed by cops and if
they do get and if they do do it and get
caught for it they have the means and
yeah they'll never see inside and then
these these guys who can't make bail or
then stuck in jail for
you know ages and then yeah are forced
to commit other crimes or go through all
sorts of heinous [ __ ] that's going on in
jail yeah or or plead guilty to get out
of jail when you look at like the the
the that cycle
especially what happens i imagine a lot
of the guys that uh a lot of the folks
that you
defended
um would end up in in in city jails
would end up in rikers and like can you
just i know there's been a lot of stuff
that's been going on you know talking
about what's going on in rikers and the
horrors of that what do you see about
the effect that that has on people can
you just talk about kind of what's been
going on at rikers and yeah and your
experience with it yeah uh yeah no i i
i'm glad you brought that up um i also
really just appreciate that you are
doing this
shedding light on these issues i think
it's awesome and i think it's a great
way for you i mean it's great that
you're using your platform to do this
nice really helpful i think dude
and if you think about just the general
effect i've had on you in your life yeah
i mean he got to it a little bit in the
beginning but sort of at looking up to
me as a team i was the captain yeah i
was the captain of the baseball team
that's how i conduct myself in life with
curiosity with courage yeah with with
just just overall just kind of just like
i have a beautiful life aspect yeah i'm
going to excuse myself so you guys just
enjoy the wrestling yeah but anyways i'm
honestly i i'm happy that i don't have
to call you captain anymore
i mean that's uh oh i do you do
anyway go ahead go ahead sorry um anyway
captain uh yeah so in terms of what's
going on right now
just explain explain before you do that
explain to the [ __ ] who don't
know the difference between
you you you get arrested you're not you
you get charged with the crime you're
not convicted of a crime and if you
can't pay bail you go to [ __ ] jail
this isn't prison this isn't people have
been found guilty by yes uh a a a a jury
of their peers these are people who the
police have said we caught you doing
this and that they could totally
whether they're innocent or guilty at
this point we don't know exactly right
yes
um yeah and then what happened that's
exactly right so
um you you get arrested uh you are just
accused you see a judge a judge then
decides um whether or not to set bail uh
which is an amount of money that you
have to pay in order to get out of jail
and um you know and for
for folks that need a public defender um
they're
they're generally speaking not gonna
have that
money to pay bill obviously depends on
the case and the amount of bail but um
but just
thousands and thousands of people are in
jail right now um because bail has been
set they have not been convicted of
anything and they can't afford and
sometimes for a long period of time
really long like what like what like
what what's the longest you've heard of
somebody who's just been in jail
awaiting bail uh i mean i had a trial in
the bronx that took three and a half
years to get to trial um where he was
acquitted
and
and he was in he was equipped and he was
what was he accused of attempted murder
he was in rikers the whole time he was
in rutgers yeah yeah um
yes so that's not at all unheard of i
mean
sort of that in and of itself is
uh
is a
a huge i think
um injustice that you're going to jail
because you can't afford to pay bail
what can happen in a place like rikers
in terms of committing other crimes
being exposed to the danger to your body
what what can happen there what has
happened yeah so it's um it's an
incredibly dangerous place it's
physically dangerous it's medically
dangerous
it's obviously psychologically
dangerous
and so
it's a very very
um
violent place it's a national
embarrassment it's a national
embarrassment right that's exactly right
um 15 or 16 people i think died this
year
um
from suicide that happens a decent
amount i mean way more than it ever
should uh i mean one is sort of too many
um people die from
uh physical violence people die from
medical neglect um
and
um
and it's just a really
dangerous violent place
and so if you think about you get sent
there
you can't pay bail
you are in hell
um
and then
you know what i think compounds
the problem is a lot of people at that
point get offered a plea right and so
you can't pay bail
you're not getting out it takes
it can take literally years for you to
get a trial and so somebody gets a plea
offer that's like you plead guilty right
now to a misdemeanor or a felony and you
get probation um and
your choice at that point is
do you want to
plead guilty
uh totally irrespective of whether you
did it or what the strength of your case
but if you plead guilty right now you go
home
and if you don't you wait probably two
years in jail in this you know hell hole
for your trial which you might lose um
and you know and then you have you sort
of layer on top of that i'm getting
i don't want to get too far afield but
you layer on top of that
um the so-called trial penalty which is
you go to trial and you lose
um
you're looking at a significant uh
sentence that gets sort of
amplified by virtue of the fact that
a judge is sort of upset with you for
having
put everybody put everybody through this
so as a public defender oftentimes are
you telling people to plea
um so that's a great and really hard
question so
number one i
in
in seven years as a public defender i
don't think i ever had a single person
turn down a plea
um that gets them out of jail
not one so your bottom line is like
let's keep you out of jail well my
bottom line is like is to advise you the
client to make the best decision for you
and so um
there were plenty of times
i
um
you know wanted to say i mean i i feel
like so my job is to say here's here's
what you're charged with
here's what i think the strength of the
case is um here's what the offer is
uh here's when i think you may go to
trial and i think we have a good shot i
i have an appreciation for
young people being young people
um
and
i think i have an appreciation for i
think i have a sort of knee-jerk uh
antipathy towards bullies which i think
you do too
um
and
i
it has made me gravitate towards wanting
to fight for people who sort of at root
are good people
but they did something dumb
that might be very human
that you know i might know plenty of
people who have also done
but who may
find themselves having their lives
completely destroyed for it
um
and so
uh and so i'm just like i think drawn to
and i guess in some sense feel like a
sense of responsibility to
people that i feel like are bullied by
the system or
you know haven't been given a fair shake
but are facing
really severe consequences
far more severe than they should
how do you get people to care about
criminal justice reform and the way that
like public sentiment has has turned
towards police reform yeah because you
know you can argue that the the actual
criminal justice reform
impacts a much broader swath of people
at the end of the day but it sort of
sits in the background in this country
as a thing that that people don't talk
about or think about like right how do
you get people to think about that in in
the same way yeah um
i mean you know it
to some degree
people think about it more when you have
like
um you know we have social media and
cell phone videos and and people see a
lot more
uh injustice i think and and it uh
it gets talked about more
but you're right it doesn't um
it doesn't
seem to rise to the level of real
fundamental systemic change
and
how do you do that um i'm not sure
change the world buddy yeah i'll try
yeah okay but
this is helpful i mean to have
you guys
have this conversation with people
um
and use your platform to like
have these discussions is
is
great and i think we need more of this i
got one more too before we end before
you
just
explain a little bit about about your
pops dude and growing up with like like
like growing up in a house with a
magician for for a dad like that was the
coolest [ __ ] thing ever yeah your
dad's a beast ass magician yeah and like
yeah just explain that like what's that
like dude yeah well i i have the coolest
dad in the world i'm sorry guys i know
you guys think
you know other people do but i did um
yeah so my dad um is both a lawyer and a
magician he's an arbitrator
um in terms of his his uh legal
profession and he's also i can see the
billboard now by the way yeah right
makes your troubles disappear yeah
uh my dad had a company called um
collector's workshop and he would build
magic for
uh for other magicians um and and and it
got pretty
pretty big time so he was building magic
for david copperfield and um
yeah i mean he's he's the best
my mom's the best too by the way
so uh yeah so i was very i was blessed
i still
awesome man am to see you man you too
you really appreciate you doing this man
you guys are just great to see you man
yeah we gotta we should do this every
week
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff it'd mean a lot to us
i hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself